we are absolutely thrilled uh to have
Simon with us today uh the way we'll do
this format will be about an hour and a
half um a little bit will be dialogue
and then really the floor is yours to
ask him any
questions uh it is so fun to see so many
friendly
faces uh this one is for our hcli alums
I say it well and um uh and let me just
quickly go through a little quick intro
um so
thank you for joining us I think when
you left your program we said the
learning doesn't stop there and this is
exactly what we mean uh by this I have
this plugin because I know I'm not going
to have any time to do it later which is
our upcoming programs uh we do have four
that are coming up uh we have our this
is new design your work life um and
that's with Bill Bernett from Stanford
we're kind of his partner here in Asia
and so uh this is all about kind of
using design principles uh to create a
happier better life it's a different
type of program for us and from anything
that you probably have done yourselves
with us because it's only two days um
and so it's quite quick and we're going
to do many um uh modules of this
throughout the year um the second one
some of you are Lums um I'm looking
around the room of our HR leaders
program uh we've decided to do this a
couple of times this year we have a HR
leaders program coming up in November um
aflp and I know there are a lot of
people here from
aflp um which is our program for our
financial leaders that when launches in
November and finally this is a new one
for us an Aion leaders Business program
um which has been sponsored with Hitachi
who wants us to build something for the
Aion region uh that has that focus and
so that's going to be something that's
interesting um it's new uh and uh we're
kind of really excited about putting
together that curriculum okay so for
without further Ado let's go to the next
next slide uh you know I I'm so happy to
see so many of you here when I Google
Simon sinck in 0 41 seconds I get
7.2 million
responses it's true this morning I just
did it um and uh so there's so much
that's known about him and when it was
shared uh that he was coming uh he's
here as a guest for a Formula 1 week and
I had to get us in there so we're really
excited to have you here uh Simon's
written uh a number of books and uh I
guess the other well you're three there
he's actually written five um and I know
that uh some of you have read some I
hope that you brought some for to be
autographed um but he also has the
fourth most viewed Ted Talk do you know
that yeah yeah which pretty
amazing
you know I told my son that this morning
and I said you know you can come if you
want I said you know he said I said
fourth most viewed Ted Talk I said 62
million views he goes but I haven't seen
it I'm like you better go watch it so I
sent it to him okay wonderful so um
first question uh Simon for you is you
know there there were 7.2 million
results uh that came up um what what's
something about you that we wouldn't
find on Google
I mean there's are like about 18.4
million things excellent
um I think I think most people don't
realize that I I consider myself an
artist not a business
person um and I love an artist's
sensibility um and um the idea of you
know art I think an artist sensibility
is about managing chaos
you know I think that's where creativity
comes from it's the ability to find
patterns in the middle of
insanity and it's not just fine arts or
creative arts but you know entrepreneurs
as well not all and it's it's I think
it's also just as an aside you know
there's a difference between a small
business owner and an entrepreneur a
small business business owner owns a
small business an entrepreneur solves
problems and you have entrepreneurs
insides corporations as well you know
and they don't necessarily own
businesses to me an entrepreneur is a
mindset and it's a creative mindset um
and it's all about chaos and managing
chaos um so I think most people don't
realize that about me that I I Define
myself as as a as a as an
artist um and that's how I sort of solve
problems as well excellent um with the
designer uh mindset I love that um you
know you uh I can't help but ask this
question we were just at a a different
talk and I was kind of sitting there
like I really want to ask this question
but I really want to get into this his
talk how did you get into this space you
you studied cultural anthropology
anthropology yeah yeah well I mean this
is this is anthropology I mean even when
I was a student you know where many of
my colleagues were fascinated by sort of
like the Bongo Bongo and you know some
other Amazonian tribe that had 17 people
in it you know that made no sense to me
um I wanted to I was much more
interested in this sort of our own lives
and our own cultures so you know I lived
in my own petri dish um I didn't have to
travel far and wide for for for field
work I would go to bars and watch mating
rituals and I did an independent the
yeah it's really fun by the way you can
do it if you're so inclined if you go to
bars and restaurants to try and guess
which couples are on a first date just
by reading just by reading the body
language it's easier it's easier than
you think but it it's fun you know I
find that entertaining and uh um
uh or I did an independent study while I
was in college on self-confidence and
leadership ability because both people
people who are secure and insecure make
both good and bad leaders so what's the
correlation and so you know I was in
student government and what they don't
know is I wrote papers on all of them um
on all the other people that I worked
with so I I was always in it um and I've
so I've always been curious about people
and human behavior um and so
uh I had an experience I I I was I
started a business myself I had a
marketing consultancy and superficially
everything was fine we had a good
business um we had great clients you
know better clients than I should have
for the the years I'd been in business
we did good work um and I got to the
point in after about four years in
business that I didn't want to do it
anymore and um The Joy had gone and I
was very embarrassed because
superficially everything was good and so
I don't want to tell anybody like oh I
don't want to go to work anymore because
because it sounded like oh poor you you
know and so I kept it to myself and if
any of you have ever gone through any
kind of Darkness if you keep it to
yourself it just gets worse and that's
what happened to me uh it got worse and
worse and worse and I got paranoid and
like I was convinced I was going to go
bankrupt I was convinced I was going to
get evicted I mean like all of the
insanity none of which was rational um
and uh and I was really good at lying
hiding and faking and pretending that I
was happier more in control and more
successful than I really felt and it
wasn't until a very close friend of mine
came to me and said something's very
wrong I don't know what it is but
something's very wrong and I came clean
and you know when you have a friend who
cares about you it is a and you feel
like you have someone who's got your
back you find the energy and the courage
to solve what seemed to be unsolvable
problems and that's what what happened
to me once I had a friend uh who was
co-conspirator in my in my pain um all
of my energy wanted to find a solution
and the solution that I found which it
then became the Golden Circle and start
with Y like I knew what I did and I knew
how I did it but I couldn't tell you why
and I realized that was the the crisis
of passion I'd lost my passion because I
didn't know why and the model that I put
together which has now become a thing um
was only designed to help me that's it
and it worked so then I showed it to my
friends and my friends started making
phra life changes and starting
businesses and quitting jobs and and
then they said well you share it with
our friends and I literally would go to
someone's apartment in New York City and
stand in the living room and talk about
a thing called start with why and help
people find their why for 100 bucks on
the side so it really was totally
organic this wasn't supposed to be my
career that's an incredible story
completely not expected a great
friend continues to be yeah absolutely I
mean I love um one of the things that
you talk about is that leadership can be
learned we start a lot of our programs
like that to talk about that there are
qualities that you can learn and you can
hone your leadership skills um is there
you know kind of going a little bit
deeper what what what what do you think
are the major attributes of leader right
now yeah and by the way leadership is a
learnable practicable skill I love that
um we are firm Believers but yeah I mean
that that's what it is um
uh so you know much is made like you see
these articles in you know various
business
Publications you know Vision Charisma
you know I know some amazing leaders who
are't big Visionaries and I know some
amazing leaders who they don't seem to
have a lot of Charisma either like
they're kind of like quiet and sit in a
corner right um and yet they are great
leaders um having met a lot of some a
lot of them with various and diversified
person alties the one characteristic
that I'm very very comfortable saying
that all of the leaders I've met have is
courage um and you know you could rank
Integrity there but I think it takes
courage to have integrity you know to do
the right thing in the face of
overwhelming pressure to do something
different to speak truth to power you
know all those Integrity things that
takes courage um it is very difficult to
lead you know I think we we we celebrate
it but I don't think people realize just
how hard it is um I the only analogy I
would offer is parenting you know having
a kid is so fun but raising a kid is
excruciating sorry did I say that it was
a little too quick you
[Laughter]
little um uh it's really difficult and
it's often thankless and it's often
lonely and it's often exhausting and
it's often infuriating it's often
frustrating and you screw it up on a
regular basis and you're like that's it
I've screwed up my kid for life you know
um um and yet for some reason it's one
of the most rewarding if not the most
rewarding thing you'll ever do in your
life for these unexpected glimmers you
know when you catch your 5-year-old
sharing with your four-year-old when you
check to make sure your 8-year-old is
sleeping to find out that they're under
the blankets with a flashlight reading
you know um the first job the first
school play you know all of these
unexpected glimmers make all the
sacrifice and exhaustion worth it and
Leadership is the same you know
leadership is um uh lonely very often um
thankless very often um unfair like if
everything goes right you have to give
away all the credit and everything goes
wrong you have to take all the
accountability well that sucks um uh uh
but it is those unexpected little
glimmers like when your team rallies
around to help them to help each other
when someone when somebody's struggling
or when they solve an unsolvable problem
and you sit back and you be like yeah
that's my team you know and it makes it
all worth it
um did you did you did you ever does the
do we know did you ever teach why
leaders exist why we have leaders
no this is interesting what's
that yeah right exactly exactly yeah uh
no but the the you know um there was a a
movement for like five minutes where a
couple of organizations attempted to be
leaderless oh yeah right or like the 99%
movement in the United States was the
leaderless and the minute organization
says we don't believe in leaders I
guarantee you it's going to
collapse um and not because it's not
idealistically uh appealing it's because
it violates our biology and our
anthropology it just it's not going to
work we are biologically hierarchical
Anon um and this is not a bad thing it
is born out of necessity and evolution
to help us survive so if you go back um
in time like 50,000 years
ago um early Homo Sapien for thousand
tens of thousands of years uh lived in
populations no bigger than 150
people um didn't change until we started
farming about 12,000 years
ago um and there's a very practical
problem that exists which is as
individuals we're junk we're not very
smart we're not strong but in groups
we're amazing we're incredible we're you
know solving problems and lifting heavy
objects in in groups um and these are
very dangerous times and so we have to
rely on each other um and so we make a
deal like if there's danger wake me you
know um but these are all also austere
times we're all hungry and the hunters
go out they bring back food and they
dump it on the ground we all rush into
eat because we're all hungry and if
you're lucky enough to be built like a
rugby player you can shove your way to
the front of the line if you're the
artist of the tribe you get an elbow in
the face and this is not a very
conducive system to cooperation because
if you punch me in the face this
afternoon probably not going to wake you
and alert you to Danger tonight and so
the tribe is going to get killed and the
species is going to die and so we
evolved into hierarchical animals we're
constantly assessing and judging each
other you know um where we sit in the
pecking order and sometimes that pecking
order is formal like we have rank
structures in our company needs and so I
know who outranks me and I know where I
sit in the pcking order um and when
someone outranks me we show difference
right um like if you're a senior and you
left your coat in the other room someone
will go get your coat for you and if
you're a junior and you left your coat
in the other room you getting your own
coat that's just how it works right and
if somebody famous or somebody that you
know that is recognizable so social
status now you'll hold the door open for
them and you'll come home and you'll
leave and be like I hold the door open
for Sten spiel bir you know like you're
going to brag about doing something for
someone that they can perfectly well do
themselves because we like to do things
for people who are rank Us in the social
hierarchy right um and so once we assess
that someone is Alpha to us we we show
difference and so we allow our Alphas to
eat first our Alphas get first choice of
meat and first choice of mate so I may
not get to eat first but I'm guaranteed
a meal and I don't get a nail bow in the
face good system for cooperation
right um and this exists today by the
way um if you a senior in the
organization you'll get a better parking
space you'll get a nicer office you'll
get a higher salary and no one
absolutely zero people are morally
offended by those perks not a single
human being is morally offended that
someone who's more senior than you in
the organization gets a higher salary we
might think you're an
idiot but we're not morally offended by
it right but here's the best part the
group is is not dumb we don't give our
Alphas all these perks for nothing just
cuz you're senior there's a deep-seated
social
contract that when danger threatens the
tribe the person who's actually stronger
actually smarter actually better fed
there's an expectation that you're going
to rush towards the danger to protect us
that's why we gave you all those perks
they are not
free and so we don't mind that our
senior people have more but when danger
threat with the organization we want to
know that you're going to protect us
even sometimes before yourself and then
we will give you our love and our
loyalty where the social contract breaks
down is when the leader puts thems first
so we've seen this happen many of times
when there's scandals in organizations
where a leader makes tons of money which
we don't mind but when there is a bad
economy they announce huge L rounds of
layoffs and the leader keep keeps their
fat salary or worse there's no bad
economy we just missed our arbitrary
projections that we told the analy so
we're very profitable just not as
profitable as we promised so you lose
your job and that's where the outrage
comes from the outrage comes from the
fact that you've violated the
deep-seated social contract so the
reason I say leadership is difficult and
the reason I say leadership requires
courage is because we all want the perks
of leadership but how many of us are
willing to fulfill our responsib as
leaders and that's an entirely different
subject and where you command love and
loyalty is if people feel seen people
feel heard people feel understood people
feel like they matter and that you care
about them as a human being and that
they don't care they'll give you all the
difference in the
world I'll I'll I'll finish with one
story how many many of you heard the
story I've told about the ceramic cup
Styrofoam cup no good it'll be a
wonderful and new for everybody
here um
the true story there was a former under
Secretary of Defense who was invited to
speak at a large conference like a
thousand people and in the middle of his
remarks he was holding a cup of coffee
in a styrofoam cup and he and he looks
down and he smiles and he interrupts
himself and he says you
know last year I I was still the under
secretary and I spoke at this exact same
cence and last year they flew me here
business class there was someone waiting
for me at the airport to drive me to the
hotel someone had already checked me
into the hotel and I just went back you
know they took me up to my room I came
down in the morning there was somebody
waiting for me in the lobby and they
brought me to the same venue they took
me through to the back entrance and they
took me into a green room and they
handed me a cup of coffee in a beautiful
ceramic cup he says I'm no longer the
under secretary I flew here coach I took
a taxi from the hotel to the from the
airport to the hotel I took another taxi
this morning to the venue I came in the
front door found my way backstage and I
when I asked somebody do you have any
coffee they pointed to the coffee
machine in the corner and I poured
myself a cup of coffee into this here
Styrofoam cup was never meant for me it
was meant for the position I held I
deserve a styrofoam
cup and the great leaders all recognize
that you can enjoy the ceramic cup you
can enjoy the first class you can enjoy
the nicer office absolutely enjoy it but
they're not giving it to you
they're giving it to the position you
hold either in the company or in the
social hierarchy we all deserve a
styrofoam cup and for the leaders that
REM are remember that you'll do just
fine you're reminding me so earlier
today um Simon spoke to the Civil
Service College uh to some of our senior
um civil servants and in the Civil
Service people are referred to as DS PS
Etc I remember asking the question well
you know isn't it nicer if we just say
Pauline or you know Etc they said No
it's it's actually it's a reminder that
it's the
position uh it's not it's not about them
right personally it's about the position
so kind of that story reminds me of that
yeah okay um a few other questions and
we've talked we know that we've kind of
gone through this crazy covid
situation um technology another kind of
big wave of change has disrupted the
workforce um what do you feel are like
some challenges or um suggestions that
you would have uh for us I mean it's a
group of very very senior leaders here
uh with companies Business Leaders um
what suggestions would you have for us
to deal and cope with some of the
changing tides um as Business Leaders I
mean
there we know some of them uh a
generation and population that doesn't
want to come back to work yeah um uh a
generation largely generation that has a
different definition of what full-time
employment
is like who says I have to work
full-time for one company I can work
full-time for two companies but we pay
you your full salary and we pay you
benefits you can't work for anybody else
why not I mean I don't think that's been
resolved of what the definition of
full-time employment is especially when
I don't keep normal
hours um what the definition of of the
value of a job is like some people want
to have ambition and they want to move
up the ranks and some people don't
just want to get to work and make a bit
of money and pay their bills and they
don't really care
about progress up you know they want to
do good work and be treated well they
still take pride in their work they're
not lazy they just they're not career
Hunters you
know that's something different but yes
quiet quitting is also a thing which I
have an exception I I don't like the
term quiet quitting because I think it's
nonsense and I'll tell you why quiet
quitting is what senior people say about
Junior people right but when we talk
about ourselves we say I'm looking for
work life
balance so it's so you know Junior
people don't say that they're quiet
quitting what senior people say of
Junior people so but yes that is still a
thing um
uh so I think the the the way to combat
all of these things or manage all of
these things look the list goes on
uh is to be very open and honest about
it um to have a conversation and to make
the um uh implicit
explicit um this is can be said of
relationships of all kinds by the way
when you take implicit tensions and you
make those tensions explicit even if you
don't have resolution it at least
normalizes it um so to say things like
uh these are strange times where we
don't really
know what full-time employment means we
say to the team or I know that we're
many of us are still struggling with
like what kind of careers do we want and
do we even want to work here do I even
want to work hard or what does that even
mean and just having the conversation
out loud tells everybody like I know you
know you don't have to hide these things
I know it's like kid our kids can't
imagine that we ever got drunk or
anything anything when we were younger
you know it's like they forget that we
were young at one point like all of the
idiot things that they do we've done all
those
things um not me of course but yeah I'm
just going to say no I'm sure um uh but
uh I think when you when you when you
make it loud it allows for discussion to
happen and so I I I try and do this even
in my company I try to relieve the
tension by talking about these things um
so even when we've gone through
difficult times like we were hit very
hard by um the great resignation I mean
I'm only a small team 27 people and we
lost seven people over the great
resignation which when you're a little
company over the course of 2 months I
mean it's it's
humiliating it's
debilitating you there's nothing else
we're talking about or thinking about
we're not growing or being ambitious or
innovation we're just just praying
another person doesn't quit this week um
and I was very open about it as rib and
like look this is a really tough time
and I'm I'm it's very difficult and I'm
struggling with it and it's humiliating
and embarrassing and I'm trying so hard
to do the right thing and people are
leading for different reasons so there's
not even one thing I can fix and I I you
know but I'm I want you to know I'm I
care and I'm trying I was just very open
about it um the irony is is the team
that I was left with is freaking out
amazing okay good yeah I mean that's uh
I think something that everybody's been
experiencing right losing amazing people
that you've done everything that has has
worked in the past uh you know
weent yeah exactly um do you think that
we're just in a new era where this is
the new Norm no no I don't I I think
it's the dust is not settled yet you
know we didn't like I said there's so
many unanswered questions and we were
talking about a little bit at lunch
which is you know there's a group of
people who don't want to come back to
work because they like working from home
but the same group of people is
suffering from increased levels of
depression and anxiety well of course
because you're all alone at home and
you're not amongst people you're not
building relationship which is how you
manage stress relationships is how you
manage stress and so the problem is if
we force them to come back to work they
don't come back to work depressed and
anxious because the little time they've
been at home which only reinforces their
narrative that it's work that's making
me depressed and anxious and they want
to go back
home that is as I'm yet
unresolved um so there's a lot of that
that that's happening cuz remember how
work was before Co right you go to work
and then after work you meet your
friends and and you all vent about
work you have a meal you have a drink
and everybody complains about their boss
and then you go home and you repeat it
you know and that's what Fridays and
Saturdays were after work you meet your
friends Friday right and then after Co
when Co struck that relief system that
very healthy uh
therapy was taken away cuz there was no
after work and so all we did was spend
time with our colleagues and co-workers
on Zoom all the time and then after work
we just did nothing we played video
games we watched TV and even if we
called a friend it wasn't hours of
venting and hanging out joking and the
therapy and the catharsis it was taken
away and so stress went up dramatically
and because we still want to get it out
we took it out with the person who was
willing to listen at work and what we
didn't know is everybody was talking to
the same
person and I don't think we realize what
we've done to each other and I'm not
sure that that's been relieved and
that's yet another reason why coming
back to work is important and why going
out with your friends after work is
important other words staying at home
the whole time is just not healthy yeah
yeah it's a a lot of we have a lot of
hrlp alums here um this is the HR
leaders and you are trained uh to kind
of turn that off I'm looking at some
heads here uh because you get that as
your job but you know when it's the rest
to the leadership Force um or just
Workforce uh that's kind of you're
empathetic because that makes you also a
good leader um and but you have to need
to release yourself you need to be able
to go with your friends and vent about
all the idiots who came to see you today
you know it's like that's fine it's it's
healthy it's healthy the venting is
healthy because if you didn't you would
actually take that stress out on people
so do you feel people should come back
you feel like to work yeah yeah I mean
we're 100% virtual company but I've been
100% virtual for 15 years and so what we
were really good at it and when Co hit
we like you another day at work um but
we also recognize that being a
distributed Workforce is actually more
work not less work because Isaac Stern
the famous violinist said music is what
happens between the notes well in a
company trust is what happens between
the
meetings um where you're talking to
somebody who you into the meeting you're
talking to somebody when you walk out of
the meeting and that's usually where the
decisions get made you bump into
somebody and I guarantee it happened
here you were chatting with people you
haven't seen in a while how are you
going to see you when you're getting a
coffee before you came in and you're
going to do it when you're done right
and when you bump into somebody in the
wholeway like oh I meant to tell you oh
by the way that client let me tell you
the decision that we made and all these
little by themselves innocuous
interactions over the course of time
build up in a Thing Called trust and the
correlation is just look at any friend
or relationship like if you have a
friend it didn't you weren't friends on
day one it's all the little things that
you eventually a friendship blossomed
it's the same thing well we took that
away and so we as a company knew that
and so when you have a distributed
Workforce it's not less work it's more
work because you now have to create all
of those things um artificially because
there is no between the meetings it's
turn on Zoom have the meeting turn off
Zoom that's it and so we do
um we do we used to do on Mondays but
now we do on Wednesdays but we do
Wednesday
huddle where the whole team comes
together the whole company comes
together we're small and we talk about
not work we make a couple small
announcements and then whoever's leading
huddle they could do whatever they want
and we go into breakout sessions for 12
minutes with three or four people and we
just talk about whatever did you see
this movie oh my God my kids are driving
me crazy right and it's very human
there's no discussion at work but we do
this because otherwise there's no
socializing and we encourage people to
get on planes and visit each other in
each other's cities and have hackathons
to solve a problem and we have an
annual Summit where we all come together
anual upset we come together so we we
still create human interaction in
pockets and we encourage people to use
the telephone rather than Zoom weirdly
it's
a I I think it's a better medium and I I
mean I can tell you why
so
Zoom doesn't NE so I'm a I'm a Pacer
okay I do my best thinking when I Pace
back and St forwards so when I'm on the
phone solving a problem I can Pace on
Zoom I can't F okay um or it's fake eye
contact right so I'm staring at your
eyes but that's not where my camera is
so what you see is this
right um um or you spend the whole time
looking at
yourself um because you
know you know so you're staring at
yourself that's there some great human
connection there um or there's excessive
and weird politeness right like
everybody's on
mute and then you unmute to speak and
then you mute and never interrupt
anybody well have you ever been in a
real meeting it's noisy and you
interrupt each other all the time and
nobody's offended by it because it's
idea generation and things are happening
and this is why you cannot have uh
brainstorming on Zoom because it's not
chaotic and so I've I've tried it in
small you can't do it on a big meeting
but like four or five people I make
everybody stay
unmuted I want interaction I want
Interruption I want a little bit of
Madness and it's
better
um but it's all fake and I find that
when you pick up a telephone
weirdly um uh it's less polite and like
if somebody's distracted on on Zoom you
can tell when somebody's
typing you know you can see when they're
distracted but nobody says anything
they're you just know that they're
distracted where if you're on the phone
and somebody's doing something like are
you typing yeah can can you stop typing
please totally fine totally acceptable I
think the phone is just a better medium
to actually have a real connection and a
diff and productive conversation um
where I think Zoom is good for basic
stuff I love that um sometimes uh in a
meeting you'll get a letter or an email
from somebody else who's in the meeting
and then you know that they're not even
paying attention to the meeting that
you're both on oh and we we're I me even
our meetings we're constantly sending
direct messages to each other you know
through Zoom yeah yeah you know do you
agree with this you
know uh but but creativity and
brainstorming does not work over resum
fact does not work does not work great
okay so we're going to bring it back to
the um so it's it it's it you takes more
work it's harder harder to have a
virtual company and most companies don't
put in the work yep yep yep like to have
a whole meeting where you don't talk
about work companies don't want to do
that it's very true um I don't know if
you have the answer to this question uh
I can guarantee you I have an opinion
okay very likely so you've been advising
lots of different companies and um and
you you've traveled quite a bit uh I
think this is your first time though in
Singapore no it's my third is it really
okay great um somebody had given me
incorrect information do you have you
like noticed
H yeah okay thanks I love it
years so it's really maybe not that long
no no no no it's not that long the last
time I was here was
probably probably probably been a
decade it's probably been 10 years for
leadership stuff yeah yeah I came here
for Apple actually they had a big Summit
here and I came I think that was the
last time I was here with Joel palone I
remember that um it was an education
Summit okay anyway okay yeah anyway
we'll go down I almost forgot my
question we're both very jet likeed um
but my question is have you notice any
differences in leaders in leadership in
Asia versus
in the other countries that you have
consulted with simple answer is yes oh
great tell us tell us more yeah so uh
there's two two two things I would I
would propose um there's this idea of
Honor that has been lost in the west in
the United States like nobody like the
concept of chivalry is gone and the word
honor is not used in business it's not
even used in society in the United
States he would never describe somebody
as honorable now if you come from the
military yes they still use the term
honor I'll call somebody in the military
and be like hey do you like this guy
like oh yeah yeah super honorable you
know and honor has nothing to do with
trustworthiness or intelligence or
reliability you can be all those things
and still be dishonorable you know to me
honor is the
willingness uh uh it's it's not taking
advantage of somebody's pain for
personal gain it's not it's putting
aside The Leverage that you may have
because it's the right thing to do you
know um and uh and I find that that
concept of Honor still exists here which
I think is important in business I'd
like to bring it back to the United
States and I do I talk about it so
there's still a sense of Honor like your
word your reputation that it's not just
transactional and it's not just who's
got the best deal there they want to do
business with honorable people so that
still exists which leads to the second
thing which is relationship which is
here you have you have meetings and the
entire meeting goes by and nobody talked
about business you talk about all kinds
of other things and it's about getting
to know somebody in relationship and
looking them in the eye and can I trust
you and in the United States it's become
excessively transactional where we do
business with people who we may not like
because it's a better deal we're in Asia
I think I'll turn down a good deal
because I don't I don't know if I like
you you know I don't know if you're a
good
person um and I I think that's good um
so the value of relationships the value
of spending the time to build
relationships before you get um create a
business relationship I think is still
very alive here and take pride in that
it matters yeah that's something to
definitely be proud of so I'm going to
go to you now uh to any questions that
you might have uh for Simon so David you
want to ask your
question thank you um just to follow on
from your point about honor is that
something that leaders in the west have
caused the loss of Honor or you know
coming back to the point why leadership
matters how did that come about but the
first question I really wanted to ask
was when you lost your passion was there
something that happened that caused you
to lose your passion and did you try to
reignite that passion before you thought
and then your friend came along I don't
know why I lost it I don't know couldn't
I don't I don't know what events
happened um I think what happened was I
mean I can tell you some of the
circumstances which I'm sure contributed
to it which is you know when you start a
business it's exciting there's a
statistic that hangs over your head that
over 90% of all new businesses fail in
the first three years and once and so
that's if you're a little bit
competitive and you like bad
odds that's fun and I'd beat that I now
join in a very elite group in the world
that said you've survived three years
and my fourth year became about building
and I realized that I had built a
business out of force of personality
you know I was in every meeting made
every decision I was Chief cook and
bottle washer and when you start to have
some success you get a even just a
little bit of scale that doesn't work
and and I didn't have the skill set on
how to build a structure I could just
run on force of Personality which is
fine if you want to be a solopreneur but
you can't build a business that way and
so I think I what I had reached I
reached a Peter principal where my
ability to build structure um
capped
out and I didn't want to admit that the
single best lesson I learned out of that
whole experience was and the biggest
mistake I've made in my life is um I
don't have to know everything and I
don't have to pretend I do and so the
since that day I've learned to say I
don't know I need
help and turns out I was always
surrounded by people who wanted to help
me they just didn't know I needed it
because never
asked um and so I'm really good at
saying I don't know and I need help now
and don't build anything by myself and
don't feel like I have to I don't feel
like I have to be the smartest person in
the room I don't feel like I have to
have more credibility than anybody else
I don't mind any of those things I let
go of all of that baggage and a lot of
us still carry that baggage that we
think if we're in the leaders we have to
have all the answers we have to be the
smartest person we have to be better at
everybody else's job than they are
because that's what makes us a leader
and we falsely confuse our credibility
as a leader is not tied to our
intelligence it's tied to our ability to
see those around us rise
that's what it means to be a
leader so if you can shed those demons
that pretty um
empowering I think the West has lost its
honor I think you can it's been a steady
drum beat it's been a slow decline I
don't think it happen overnight there's
no one event but you know in the 1970s
Milton Friedman The Economist theorized
theorized that the responsibility of
business was to maximize profit within
the bounds of the wall no mention of
Ethics you know know and that definition
which was just the theory was embraced
by a class of leader corporate leader in
the day and they used it to justify new
behaviors in business so for example the
concept of mass layoffs to balance the
books um which is now normal you know
CEOs very comfortably go on TV and say
we missed our numbers we're having a
round of layoffs like you're profitable
just not as profitable as you promised
um so normal like they just do it very
openly that that did not exist as a
behavior did not exist prior to the
1980s didn't exist you only had layoffs
for existential
reasons
um the Jack Welch the rise of Jack Welch
who I think I am trying to undo
everything he
did I think he was a terrible human
being who uh basically perpetuated
concepts of short-termism rank and yank
pitting our people against each other
inside our own companies and creating
internal competition
um uh just everything that violates
every good tenant of leadership Welch
did the opposite uh he wrote a book
called uh
winning um he wrote a leadership book
and put his own face on the
cover I mean that tells you
everything
um and the problem was that became the
model and there's an entire generation
of leader that was raised in the 80s and
90s on Milton Freedman and Jack wilch
theories and what they did was they
broke
capitalism what America has today and
and and only because America's so rich
so goes America so goes the world you
know and so as American capitalism
became bastardized the rest of the world
started copying American capitalism
because it made a lot of money right so
now that American capitalism of
short-termism and rank and yank and all
nonsense has now spread outside the
borders to the detriment of global
economies I would add
and this is not Adam Smith capitalism
that made America great this is a new
version of capitalism which is extremely
short termist and extremely broken and
the result is we're seeing a rise
against capitalism there is there's a a
populist movement of foot in the United
States whether it's Bernie Sanders or
Donald Trump left and right whether it's
Hungary or brexit or all of these things
they're all populist movements against
capitalism now they're confusing
capitalism and this version of
capitalism we want to reform capitalism
not eliminate it it's a good system but
it's very
broken uh the the decline of the middle
class and the stock market all of these
things the violation of the social
contract of leaders all of it all of it
um and I think that's contributed to the
lack of Honor which is uh Jack Welch was
not an honorable business
he was a makoi and stabby in the back if
he needed to to make a buck and and it
became normal and it took about 20 or 30
years for him to break it it's going to
take us 20 or 30 years to fix
it that's why you have to do a really
good job no no I'm not even joking like
you go to a program like this to learn a
the a kind of leadership that is
different than the ' 80s and 90s that
that has become normalized and
standardized today so that if you get it
right and you build the companies you
work for in the manner that they need to
be built then we will restore a belief
in
capitalism or we will restore a belief
in trust and cooperation up and down the
chain of command work we trust our
leaders and our leaders trust us we will
restore a model where people will
happily give 10 20 30 years to one
company rather than one year one year
one year one year we will store a model
where we derive tremendous Joy from our
work rather than tremendous stress um
there's a lot at stake here that's why
programs like this really really
matter and your biggest challenge is to
invent new incentives because all the
old incentives reward quarterly or
annual performance and basically nothing
else there's very few companies that
have successfully figured out incentives
and reward structures for cooperation
teamwork
and things like that the performance
stuff is fine but it's wul
unbalanced it's a great call to action
everybody here has a say okay
youn I asked you maybe you can introduce
yourself and your company because none
really knows don't worry about the
microphone I'll repeat the
question hi my name is ifn from great
place to work and we agree that
leadership matters the reality is
leaders today are very tight
there's so much expected of them how can
we encourage a heart of leaders across
the organization and you talk about cage
and how could we build courage if
leadership is a learnable
trade it's a very good question it's a
very hard
question um what's that that's why I ask
you oh you're very
kind um you
know this sounds corny
but group therapy is a
thing right which is we talk about
leadership being lonely and complicated
and that we're constantly putting on a
mask and acting like we have all the
answers and being tough and nothing
phases us and some of that's important
but not to the point of self-destruction
or lying hiding and faking and there's a
need for leaders to be able to vent
themselves and have catharsis and ask
for help
um there's a very important case study
um I've written about it in the infinite
game but you can go back to the original
hbr uh case study it's on the shell
Ursa
Ursa um the shell Ursa in I think it was
is an oil rig an offshore oil rig and I
think it was the
1980s and when the time when it was
built was the largest oil rig in the
world right and when you're launching
something that big and that complicated
you you're concerned about all kinds of
things and so they found a guy and they
said you're going to lead you're going
to be in charge of the crew of the shell
Orsa and as he was preparing for it um
it was in the news that this oil rig was
going to exist and this weird hippie
sort of San Francisco business
consultant reached out to him and
basically said I have something for you
to try and he was weirdly open-minded
and he was willing to go to a workshop
that she was running in San Francisco
with his son and it helped him restore a
very broken relationship with his son
and so he agreed to bring some of her
thoughts and theories to his crew and
what he did is months before they
launched to see he had all his crew and
I'm talking these are tough guys who
work on oil rigs these aren't the
leadership this is the guys who run the
oil rig and he had them sit around in a
circle and it got very extreme I
wouldn't recommend this like they were
giving each other foot massages
um uh don't want to do that uh but they
he forced them to talk and it took a few
rounds but one by one people started
opening up for example one guy had a son
who uh I think was struggling with some
terminal illness and nobody even knew he
had a son let alone a son with a
terminal illness and there was crying
and there was hugging and they were
holding space for each other and they
learned how to listen and they learned
how to hold space for each other and
they learned how to be uh
vulnerable right I would call it human
they learned how to be human around each
other and then they went out to the oil
rig and something happened which has
turns out that when you learn to be
comfortable being vulnerable with
someone that you were much more willing
to say I need help I made a mistake and
you know something's gone wrong and on
that oil rig the accident rate was one
of the lowest if not the lowest in all
of the shell organization and the entire
industry and their performance was one
of the
highest um and I think that's lacking in
business because it's uncomfortable we
don't want to do it who wants to do that
right um but I think to create spaces
where people learn how to hold space for
each other and it doesn't have to be all
personal but I actually think the
personal stuff's important um and I'll
just give you one example which is co
every single person who went through Co
suffered trauma
everyone um and every single person at
some point of the course of Co got
depressed everyone didn't happen at the
same
time and I went through mine about four
five months in I went through mine and I
didn't know what was wrong I was off my
game I I was struggling I didn't know
what it was and I called a friend of
mine who was in the military and I said
you know how do you know when you're
suffering from the trauma of
combat and he said well and there was no
leading questions I just asked him a
very open question no leading answer I
mean and so I I no leading question and
I and he said well um he says um I fall
out of my sleep cycle I start going to
bed very late and don't want to get out
of bed in the morning and I went yep and
he said and I become uh really
unproductive but I rationalize and like
oh you've been working hard it's okay
you just had an unproductive day no big
deal except I have another and another
and another I went
yep and he said I become really
antisocial I don't want to talk to
anybody and I definitely don't want to
ask anybody for help and I went yep and
I realized I was suffering
trauma and so the next question was well
how do I deal with it and he said well
force myself back into a sleep schedule
okay I can do that he says I allow
myself to be unproductive but I tell my
team that I'm unproductive right now and
I forced myself to ask for
help and so I did that and I went to my
team in an open phone call on a whole
team I said I'm going through something
I don't know what it
is I'm not don't rely on me right
now um because I'm struggling and I'm
just not that helpful right now I'll be
okay don't worry about me but but I just
need you to know that I'm not in a good
place but I'm aware
and I did it out loud I did it to my
team which I think a lot of leaders
would never
do um and it did two things my my team
was patient with me they held space for
me they picked up work for me that I
that that I would ordinarily they would
have been frustrated because I let them
down and everything was fine but the
most important thing was because I had
set the example other people were
willing to say when they were struggling
and we could support them where if IID
put on a brave face every day everyone
would have put on a brave face every day
and then it would have gotten worse
and so that idea of
catharsis I did it with a bunch of
police Chiefs recently America is having
a bit of a policing
problem understatement and so I gathered
a group of really
forward-thinking modern Progressive
police Chiefs and I brought them in room
there's about 15 of them and I led the
way I went first I said look there are
many things that I struggle with as a
leader because it's lonely and and and I
have insecurities and let me tell you
what some of them are and one by one
they all started to open up in a way
that they never have because who they
opening up to they're the chiefs of
police like who they going to tell and
they're definitely going to tell each
other without me because they're all
tough and they all one by one started
opening up of their struggles their
fears their
insecurities um I mean some deep stuff
that they were revealing was incredible
and even the ones who never talked some
people didn't open their mouths came up
to me afterwards and said thank you I
needed that just the ability to hold
space and they all went back
supercharged and so there's a something
to be said
for giving leaders a safe space and by
the way you don't have to do it in your
own company like you I assume you built
relationship as you went through these
classes do go that should be your team
like I don't know if that if you have
that but those safe spaces for you to be
fully open where there's no
judgment and you can talk about anything
in any difficult terms you want is I
can't tell you how important it is for
for
for for um mental Fitness it is so
important and it gives us the goes back
to courage learning to do it in circles
like this you will have more courage
than you realize to do it at work and
know how to help people at work and do
it amongst
themselves and especially as HR
professionals I mean can I wax on about
HR professionals absolutely we've got
some star star star HR professionals
here so please do most I can't speak
about Singapore about the United States
but most HR departments are a complete
waste
um because they don't know what their
job
is they think their job is to do the
bidding of Senior Management and they
get rewarded for how efficiently they
did the
layoffs and any large company that says
if you have a problem coming to HR you
have got to be
kidding no one trusts HR R I am not
telling HR any problem I'm having you
will use it against me
right and I saw it happen firsthand it
was absolutely aart uh a good friend of
mine who's an executive at a large
company who will remain
nameless but you know the
company oh you know the company um had a
had a problem with a an employee one
somebody who reported to her there was a
tension
between
them and uh this employee thought that
she was out to get her and it was bad
and so HR got
involved um I think one of them went to
HR log a complain about the
other I think the junior one lodged to
complain about the
senior and my friend called me up and
said what do I do I'm having a meeting
with me my direct report and the HR
representative how do I what do I do in
this meeting
I said very simple um the problem is the
person doesn't feel heard that's that's
all this is okay so you have to create a
space where they feel heard that's it
not have answers not correct the fact
she's going to say things that are wrong
because you told me what happened in the
scenario and there's a misunderstanding
and it's it's just factually wrong but
don't correct them right that is your
strategy right so my friend went in and
said tell me tell me what happened and
she vented and she said go on tell me
more what else I coached her you know go
on tell me more what else go on tell me
more what else go on tell me more what
else good oldfashioned listening right
and at the
end the she felt good she felt heard she
felt seen she felt understood and the
idiot HR executive said do you want to
tell her what you want to do now and my
friend no no because what I told my
friend is that's the best outcome
3 days L later you can call up and say
can I tell you my my view on this once
the emotion has settled you can't do it
with a high state of emotion and she's
now open to hear your side of it when
she's rational again right and the HR
executive the HR representative is like
would you have to tell her what what
you're and my friend's like no no no no
I'm good this is great this is literally
great and the HR executive literally
Wasing her and then started getting
involved and saying well you said that
and literally broke it and and it was
excruciating that this RR executive was
not trained on how this very simple very
common experience on how to relieve
tension which is it's going to be multi
multipronged it's not going to be one
meetings and then everybody's done
because everybody gets their turn to
speak no no no the person who feels
wronged needs to feel heard that's
it uh and the HR executive made it
worse so um I think there's a massive
opportunity
for the HR profession to be
professionalized and reformed where you
the HR is the voice of the employee at
the executive table that is your job
that when the executives say we are
going to have a round of layoffs the HR
should be saying hold on hold on hold on
what's the issue well we need to save
10% of expenses okay okay let me go back
to the people that I represent I'm the
voice of the people here you're the
voice of Finance you're the voice of
operations you're the voice of I'm the
voice of people so I'm representing them
here I'm their Union
Leader let me go back to them and see if
we can find 10% somewhere else and you
go back to everybody and say guys uh
they're they got to save 10% and um they
they are willing to do layoffs and I
want to make that the last
resort how can we all band together and
find 10% of savings let's do this to
help each other better we should all
suffer a little than any of us have to
suffer a lot how we going to figure this
out that's HR job not be like okay you
need to do L Us by what
date um and I think there's a massive
opportunity and it goes back to honor
and it goes back to trust and it goes
back to all these things which is HR can
fix many of the broken ills and poor
leaders in all the other
positions makes me think of some um and
I'm going to get to the question in the
back in some offer letters here there's
actually a statement and I know this is
for public service that you can take
away 20% of the salary for times like
that and the idea is that rather than
firing y to put that in the contract it
is actually in the contract suffer a
little than anyone should have exactly
exactly which by the way makes morale go
up yeah yeah yeah yeah interesting okay
uh right I've said my Soap Box about HR
I have I will let's go to the back and
then Chuck is yeah hi uh my name is
chinan from tamasic
um I just wanted to pick on a point
which you raised about the fact that we
want to have a new capitalism where
people are incentivized to work in the
place for a long time rather than sort
of one year one year one year which is
really what our young people do they
move from job to job is that a failure
leadership or is it a new reality that
we need to deal with the former it's a
failure of leadership right because when
people feel taken care of when people
feel trusted when they feel like they
belong when they feel like their work
means something they're working towards
something bigger than themselves why
would they leave right right you have to
understand we have to understand we have
to remember that because things like
Jack Welch and layoffs have become so
normalized that young people have grown
up in a capitalist system where they
watch their parents lose their jobs
through no fault of their own it's not a
meritocracy you worked for company for
20 years you did good work sorry nothing
personal is just business we miss our
numbers so they've watched it happen
they've watched the company not take
care of their parents and they've been
raised not to trust companies why should
they I think they have it right and so
they come in inherently cynical and
inherently expecting that the company
would happily use their job to help
itself and then stupidly demand loyalty
back I don't blame them the company sets
the rules of the game the people are
just playing by the rules the company
set which is no
loyalty or when hardship happens the
first thing cut is like all the
leadership programs you know it's it's
the first thing that's cut it should be
the last thing to be cut well I kind of
measure the ROI on that can I you can
over
time um so I I don't think it's just
some reality because at the end of the
day great organizations that are
well-led have no problem with young
people leaving every year they just
don't have it you know ones and twoes
sure but not not nothing
significant um there's plenty of
companies that come out tremendous
loyalties from young people because
they're well LED so I don't think it's a
new reality I think it is um yet again a
condition of a broken
capitalism okay Chuck and then in the
front
Chuck hi my name is uh Chuck I have
spent 27 years in corporate mostly
imbued with the thoughts of Jack Welsh
capitalism Milton fredman you name it
it's like it's like an AA meeting yes
yes let let me start with the Journey of
vulnerability right I will I um so you
know you can imagine the first time I
saw a Simon syc video my first thought
was what is this guy all about what is
he
on uh and that's the that's the reality
of it if you've gone through the 80s and
'90s uh listening to the Jack wels
thought the Simon syx school of thought
is oh I'm an idiot is jarring I'm an
idiot yeah right yeah I'm unrealistic
idealistic and naive sure
but I've been called those things your
your words not mine your words uh no no
no I've been called those things but and
firstly I want to thank you for the
inspiration right I think I think I I
speak on behalf of many in this
audience thank
you uh and and on that I think the The
Next Step from inspiration don't worry
Dar is a question there's a question
coming uh on top of on the next step of
inspiration is aspiration I think we all
have aspiration genuine aspiration to to
bring about the simx school of thought y
right but it's difficult because you've
you've actually explicitly acknowledged
that uh human beings are
anthropologically hierarchical yep right
for survival instincts all those who you
know did not want to acknowledge
hierarchy died so this is what's
left uh but as you also said it takes
another 20 30 years to get to the new
way of handling
hierarchy I'm talking about us in the
context of knowing that Jeffrey Fifer
book on seven rules of power is still
the most popular CA in
Stanford I'm talking about the world
where Robert Green's 48 Laws of Power is
still somewhat good reading and then
that's you mhm so we got to Stage this
in and my question is how are we going
to station this
it um so how do you run a
marathon tell us one step at a time in
this in the right
direction nobody said it would be easy
and nobody said it would be fast and I'm
okay with that as long as marching
forwards you know um I just had Robert
Green on my podcast I don't think we've
released the episode yet because I read
his book and I was
like there you go thank
you and then I stopped reading I'm like
I can't even do this you know so I like
brought him on the podcast and I was
ready for a
fight and uh he's lovely he's absolutely
lovely and uh I understand why he wrote
that book and he talks about it he he
and I had a wonderful
conversation what's missing from that
book is the context right which was he
was 38 years old and every job he had he
was trying to be a
writer um he was subjected to people who
stole his ideas stabbed him in the back
screwed him over and over from the age
of 21 to
38 just just people who were threatened
by him fired him like just over and over
and over and he he was exhausted and he
happened to be walking with a guy who
had a he was a publisher you'd love to
I'd love you to write a book do you have
any ideas and he thought you know what
I've been subjected to people who are
who are jostling for power and I'm going
to write a book what how I perceive
power basically to warn everybody like
put your guard up stop being so naive
this is what the world is it's a little
bit cynical right but that's basically
what it is it's the problem is he wrote
it that's some people read it as a
manual but it's really a warning like be
aware of how your enemy works so you're
you you won't be taken advantage of um
uh because it's really how to manipulate
people um so when you ask like you know
what do we do well first of all you
write about the curriculum which is the
people who teach a lot of that stuff
they come from those Jack Welch
ideologies so of course going to choose
those books the good news
is folks like me and Renee Brown and our
books are starting to show up and at the
very minimum if they show up on the same
syllabus so at least there's a a debate
or better they're replacing the Old
Guard you know so there is a
movement and I also think the the most
the Practical movement is the leaders
themselves for you and your own
organization to say
I reject the Jack Welch way that I was
raised in I have seen the damage it
causes we have seen economic hardship
caused we've seen families destroyed by
short-termism
and self than selfishness and
shareholder Supremacy and I will not
lead and I will do everything I can to
support this organization to change the
way in which we leave for the good of
the company and by the way you look at
the best organizations like like Apple
never had
layoffs I think they've had them Pixar
had them once and they like regretted it
you know these great organizations
didn't do these
things um so there's good there's good
case studies from the from the companies
that we consider the exceptions well
there's a reason there were the
exceptions so I I think the the as a
practical matter which is this is the
Army right here and you can't and I look
I get this question all the time Simon I
I buy into all your stuff that's one the
thank you very much but I'm not
CEO how do I change the organization
when I'm not in charge where there's
like four levels up above me what am I
supposed to and the answer is of course
you can't change behaviors of somebody
you have no contact with even to
somebody people you do have contact with
no number of anonymously sent books to
senior Executives is going to change the
way they
lead although I encourage you to keep
trying um uh and the reality is you take
responsibility for the the environment
you can control so if you have influence
over seven
people people to the left people to the
right even the boss above you that's
still a human and even if they're
difficult let's have empathy maybe
they're difficult because we don't
understand the pressure upon them and if
we just work to create this little
pocket of magic what you tend to find is
when you have well-led teams those teams
outperform all the other teams and so
senior leadership either leaves you
alone or they at least are curious and
like what are you doing or somebody from
the team will eventually get promoted
out to another team and bring all the
lessons that you taught them and Lead
that team the same way and then that you
have two magic uh teams and then
somebody there gets promoted and you
have four magic teams and you have eight
magic teams and then the CEO moves on
and is and retires and before you know
it the tail wags the
dog the the having a top leader who
understands the stuff just means it's
more
efficient but it doesn't mean it's the
only way you have we have to remember
power always belongs to the people
that's why dictators fear people and
have fake elections because they want to
give the appearance of popular support
because that's where power is
derived but dictators fear the people
which is why you can't get close to a
dictator's house you have to say three
miles away and the arm's given orders
for shoot to kill right the people
always have the power always and so what
you do is you create these magical
ripples inside an organization and you
don't even need to convert everybody
it's law of diffusion you only need
about 15 to 18% of the company to fully
embrace the
ideas and that's it tip Tipping Point so
don't worry about the CEO don't worry
about the company just worry about what
you can
control thanks s much it's e it's easy
for me I run my own company then then
you have efficiency then you have
efficiency okay we have a last question
hey Simon hi uh this is Ian Wong from
UOB an honor to be here we minut it
thank you so the question is aging
Workforce yeah so what would be your um
maybe words of wisdom on how leaders uh
should organize themselves to rejuvenate
the Aging Workforce uh especially in
today's uh baau business as unusual so
that's my first question the second
question
is given the I narrative right how do
you authentically inspire the youths the
young that uh there's going to be a
great future with good
jobs uh to come yep so let's talk about
uh aging Workforce first
so um everyone but wants to feel seen he
and understood everyone wants to feel
like they matter right and an aging
Workforce starts to feel like nobody
cares about them they don't matter
there's agis and all the rest of it if
I'm a certain age I can't get a job you
know um uh uh first of all um all of the
empathy we apply to a young group we
have to apply to an aging group right
that's a big part of it the other part
is I always believe in asking people to
solve their own problems so one of the
mistakes I think we make in business is
as Leaders we think we have to have all
the answers and solve all the problems
and take anything uh you know where we
we we we commission studies and we look
at the data and then we make decisions
and then we Implement a program and we
have a a roll out schedule and we have a
change Management Consultant and then
here you go and at no point do we ever
go to the people who are actually going
to be affected by our decisions and say
here's the problem we have we're
completely open to what we would do can
you bring us some suggestions on how you
would sold this or you can do with two
or three different groups to get two or
three different points of view and I
love asking people to solve their own
problems right because a gives them a
sense of ownersh ship and B you're going
to get ideas that you never had um and
I'll give you one bad example but it'll
make the
point so this company that I talked
about Barry way Miller uh they had they
make they it's a manufacturing company
so they have a big Factory and they have
a huge machine that needed getting old
and it needed
replacing and so the way a machine is
usually replaced inside a factory is
somebody in procurement back in back
office somewhere
uh puts together a spec sheet puts
together a budget and goes out in the
market and buys a machine that's usually
how it's done that's not how they did it
at Barry weiller because it didn't make
sense to them why you would ask an
accountant to buy a machine so they went
to the two guys who work on the machine
one of them had worked on it for about
25 years the other one had a high school
equivalency degree didn't even have a
high school degree and they said to the
two guys um we need to replace your
machine you have a budget of
$750,000 go buy a machine and the guys
went out on the open market and they
looked at new machines they looked at
secondhand machines and the the sellers
said they've never had the experience
usually people show up with a tie on a
clipboard they've never had people show
up and overall and climb into the
machine before they've never had that
happen the guys ended up spending
$650,000 on a new
machine um we're proud that they saved
the company
$100,000 and by the way that machine
will never break because it's their
machine um uh but most companies
wouldn't trust some somebody with a high
school equivalency degree to spend 3/4
of a million
dolls but they are the best qualified
people my point is is go to the people
who are affected by the challenge and
ask them to solve the problem and just
give them the safe space to do it and if
there's a budget required give them a
budget because they will Sol in Prof so
that's a big one um uh what was the
second part the first part was agent War
oh AI
right right so AI is an interesting one
right and we can get into the goods and
the bads of AI but I'll just answer the
question which is a first for me by the
way usually I go down the Rabin that's a
joke by the way um feel free to laugh
anytime um uh I think it's a very simple
thing which is um fear is the thing
we're guarding against people are afraid
of AI right and it's not that it's going
to take away our jobs it's that I don't
know what's going to happen to me the
fear isn't losing the job the fear is
what's next and so if we think back you
know uh 30 years ago something like 80%
of the jobs that exist today didn't
exist prior to the internet you know it
Consulting was not a robust business
where now it's
standard um uh and so the narrative
isn't your job is going to go away the
narrative is your job is going to change
and I'll give one example I'll give me
right so in my world the writer is king
and the editor is
disposal
right what AI Can Do Is Write a bad
first
draft you don't really unless it's an
original idea so like let's take about a
press release we pay a press we pay a PR
person a lot of money because they know
how to write a press release right
that's the hard part and then the rest
of us get our grubby handl it right
that'll change that'll change cuz now
chat gbt been write a bad first draft of
a press
release editor
is going to be the
hero and so we're going to replace
writers with
editors um and so to use that example
that the jobs not going away the balance
will shut I'll give you another example
in the United States the IRS a bunch of
years ago digitized taxes it used to be
you send in the form and teams and teams
and teams that accountants read through
our tax forms and they replac it all
with computers and they offered this
massive savings you know how much the
government actually saved when we
digitized
taxes zero because yes they got rid of
all the accountants but then they had to
boost up the it departments because now
all the computers were playing reading
the taxes the net savings was Zero the
jobs changed didn't go away they just
changed the net savings will be
zero you're going to have to pay editors
more you're going to have to pay what
you used to pay
writers um and so if you help people
understand
opportunity from this to that um we
already you can major ready in uh what
do they call it in a a prompt prompter
right uh uh that that's going to become
a skill how to prompt AI so I think we
just instead of talking about your job
is going away away which is a narrative
we start talking about the new jobs that
are going to be
available I think that gets people
excited because again they're not afraid
of losing their jobs they're afraid of
that there's no job for them and so we
start talking about all the new jobs
that are going to exist like prompt
editor you know all of these things that
are going to
happen um I think that people will be
excited to explore new and they can
still have nerves the Fe but they won't
be at the uncertainty that freaks them
out so all they to do is paint a picture
of of a little more certainty than we
have
now thank you thanks and I would I mean
I'm going to just throw this out there
so I mean you can totally disagree with
me but I would offer that being a leader
is one of those jobs that's going to
stay which is which is the ability to
uh the 100% I think that the ability
because computers will replace a lot of
the mundane stuff but the job of leading
people can never ever ever be replaced
by a computer and so I think the need
for leaders the education for leaders
the curriculum for leaders is going
become more important in a highly
digitized World amen amen
[Music]
awesome Simon it was an absolute Joy I
mean I I flew back early because I I
just I couldn't I just really wanted to
be here and to meet you in person um we
we do close a lot of programs some of
you have been to recent programs where
we close with clips of Simon um so
really really appreciate your time and
making the time to to join us and you
know I think that what I take away here
is really the call to action to all of
us um to continue with the movement
because uh that's how it becomes
scalable yep so uh really thank you so
much for joining us enjoy Singapore I'm
sure that there are lots of different
suggestions here what to do uh he will
be here for the weekend having a lot of
fun but I'm going to ask you to do one
thing which is take a photo with all of
us okay so SP is gonna take
lead we're gonna do yeah if everyone's
just sitting down that's great okay